hello we're glad you joined us for this
webinar turning up the heat on thyroid
hormone analysis with LC I CTMS I am
Judi Oracle arutz and I'll be moderating
this session today's educational web
seminar is presented by lab routes the
leading scientific social networking
website and provider of virtual events
and webinars advancing scientific
collaboration and learning it brought to
you by agilent technologies agilent is a
leader in life sciences diagnostics and
applied chemical markets the company
provides laboratories worldwide with
instruments services consumables
applications and expertise enabling
customers to gain the insights they seek
affluence expertise and trusted
collaboration gives them the highest
confidence in the company's solutions
tomorrow our visit WWL intercom let's
get started
this webinar has been approved for
continuing educational credit please
click on this PE button at the bottom
left corner and follow the process to
receive your credits you can post
questions to the speaker during the
presentation while they're fresh in your
mind to do so simply type them into the
Q&A box which will open when you click
the green Q&A button at the lower left
of the presentation window questions
will be answered after the presentation
to enlarge the slide window click on the
screen icon in the lower right hand
corner of the slide window if you
experience technical problems seeing or
hearing the presentation just click on
the support button found at the top
right of the presentation window or
report your problem by clicking on the
green su na button at left
I now presented a speaker Frederic
Stratton and ph.d vice president of
quality assurance at NMS labs prior to
his current position dr. Stratman was a
medical director of toxicology and
director of high complexity platforms
mass spectrometry at a RUP laboratory
and a tenure-track assistant professor
of pathology at the University of Utah
School of Medicine
he received a MS and PhD in pathology
and Laboratory Medicine from the
University of Rochester in New York
conducted an academic postdoctoral
fellowship in the biomedical genetics
department at the University of
Rochester and completed Accomack
accredited clinical chemistry
fellowships at the University of
Washington in Seattle dr. Stratman is
board certified in clinical
mystery and topological chemistry by the
American Board of clinical chemistry dr.
Stratman will now begin his presentation
okay thank you for that introduction
certainly thank you to lab roots and to
Agilent as well for putting this on
Agilent for sponsoring this session and
then certainly to all of you who are in
attendance and listening all over the
place from what I can see in regards to
where everybody's location is so I think
that's really great there's a lot of
interest in icp-ms and mass spectrometry
very exciting time I think to be
affiliated with mass spectrometry and
clinical laboratory medicine medicine in
general so today I'm going to talk about
what I would probably say is an area
that doesn't get as much attention as
other areas of mass spectrometry and
that's inductively coupled plasma mass
spectrometry there's a good chance that
having icp-ms in the title may have
already whittled down the number of
people who are going to attend to only
those who actually use icp-ms and I
think that's really what we're trying to
push against with a seminar like this is
to talk about some of the other ways in
which we can actually use this
technology to be able to do things that
other types of mass spectrometry
specifically time-of-flight or triple
quadrupole technology typically get
thought of immediately and nobody really
sort of makes their way to icp-ms very
powerful technology very interesting
technology something I've been fortunate
to spend a lot of time using until
that's really what we're going to focus
on here today I'm going to try to
monitor the questions section to make
sure if by chance at any point I've I'm
speaking of something I don't know the
degree of expertise in the audience and
so if there's anything that you want to
ask during I will try to monitor so we
can try to answer those in real time if
not I certainly will try to get to it at
the end or if there isn't time then
certainly all of you can contact me
which I have my contact information here
it's a good chance that I I know some of
you who are in attendance and obviously
prior to this I was
ar e P in the University of Utah so this
is my updated contact information don't
have to think I'm ignoring you if you're
sending me messages to my other email
that's just not working anymore so this
is my current contact information now
part of an immense laboratories but the
work that I'll be presenting today was
done entirely while I was at a VP and
the University of Utah
so speaker financial disclosures I think
it's important just to say that I did
have a Giunta quipment for R & D while I
was at a or GP and in fact Agilent had a
was very helpful in trying to use some
of their technology in ways that a they
themselves had not typically always
thought about using it so I think that's
very interesting to get support from a
vendor lots of other vendors are helpful
as well so I don't want this to be
overly overly skewed in one direction I
will show a lot of pictures of Agilent
equipment I figured it's the least I can
do for them sponsoring this event
they've been very supportive of this
project specifically so acknowledgments
I don't typically spend time go through
one line by line for acknowledgments but
I am going to pause here just a little
bit to highlight some extremely helpful
people this is a project that I actually
took on myself I did all of the bench
work that had a huge amount of support
from quite a few people both a Terry P
as well as Agilent and a lot of that
support came right when I was
transitioning out of our EP and the
University of Utah they really helped
busy time as always in the laboratory
but they really went above and beyond
trying to make sure that I could make as
much I could get as much out of my last
few days this was about the last month
of my time there so not a complete
project but I think still shows and
illustrates some some really interesting
applications of icp-ms technology
christian law is a trace element
supervisor at a RUP extremely helpful
never never to worry when he saw me
actually in the laboratory with gloves
on but very supportive very helpful dr.
Julie ray is an orangy scientist at area
P she is officially unofficially the
queen of thyroid hormone
ar e P whether she wants to be or not so
I'll be presenting some work from her
tere veo is one of the bioanalytical
engineers at aap go-to guy for not only
applications but really instrumentation
extremely helpful very very reliable
very willing to help me in the last few
months with some very new technology and
applications and then certainly
everybody in that laboratory I mentioned
the trace and toxic elements laboratory
at a AP and then they read the Institute
who provided the funding for the work
and then Agilent mark Klinsky and Kerry
Adler mark helped with an enormous
amount of the LC setup which you'll see
is really one of the keys to making a
project like this succeed Kerry was a
scientist who worked at a BP made me
look good while I was there she's now
happily doing the same thing for Agilent
so good to see where everybody ends up
and thanks to everybody who has
participated in this so the learning
objectives for today pretty
straightforward so we're going to
discuss the basics of LC icp-ms and
we're going to look at some similarities
and differences to other types of mass
spec I have some highly technical
drawings that I've done myself that
you'll be able to see they're short
little videos to try to highlight some
of the differences between these at the
same time we're going to compare and
contrast workflows for thyroid hormones
by LC icp-ms as well as LTE tandem mass
spec so as you'll notice we're talking
about liquid chromatography as the
separation science and then it's really
about changing the detector that's
really what the crux of this discussion
is really going to be about today and
then lastly we're going to look at and
see how does LC icp-ms work for thyroid
hormones and what we're really targeting
here is the measurement of thyroid
hormones in serum a lot of paps work
that has been published has largely been
done in urine looking at third hormone
and a blog and analogs but this was
really sort of a focus on serum and a
focus on you know could we actually use
LC icp-ms why would we think about that
and that's really sort of some of the
key aspects to the day is what would
have led us to think about using LC I
PMS has the technology so talk to very
briefly about clinical and research
utility of our t3 in the truth I'm not
going to belabor this too much and
you'll see why in regards to how a
project like this sometimes presents
itself I'd love to say that sometimes
you know that all the time projects come
out of great ideas you know great
collaborations but sometimes they just
come out of need and we have to do
something to solve a problem and we turn
to whatever technology we might actually
have and one of the things that I think
is very important no matter what type of
technology you use is to understand the
limitations but also the advantages of
the different types of technology that
we have available and to make sure that
we really apply and use them and play to
the strengths of the different
technology as I talked about a little
tongue-in-cheek we have some highly
technical drawings that you'll get to
see to try to help explain some of the
basic principles across these different
type of technologies and then some early
performance characteristics and so this
is very early data I didn't want to
focus really on the method validation I
would imagine a large portion of the
audience understands what it takes to
validate a method it wouldn't really be
all that different to validate a method
by icp-ms versus triple quadrupole and
certainly some subtleties there of
course but for the most part you know
what I really wanted to focus on is you
know why would we pick this type of
technology what are the advantages
whether there disadvantages and then
focus a little bit on the front end
meaning the LC portion to look at higher
throughput testing when we might have
some limitations that we're trying to
oversee so here's the analytical
vignette so not the clinical vignette
but the analytical vignette and you'll
kind of see what I mean in regards to
not always having a great research
project to start out with whenever we're
looking for an application of Technology
so a very common scenario is that you
have send out costs for a reverse
thyroid hormone or rt3 have been on the
rise for the past six months and just
about every organization is monitoring
their send out costs as a way to try to
contain any kind of cost so certainly a
test that's on the rise you could argue
about the clinical utility you could
argue about the research utility but you
can't really argue about the cost
associated with the
going out the door so well imagine that
there's an RD oversight group in this
organization and they've asked you to
determine the cost associated with
developing a test including the
resources you'd need any equipment
required so very very typical situation
and so now we think okay well what do we
know right obviously an analyte we
haven't measured before we're going to
make the assumption that there's mass
spectrometry in this building at all as
as already but like a lot of groups it's
possible that we have expertise in pain
management
so urine toxicology therapeutic drug
monitoring so RT 3 is a bit of a
different animal and so that's going to
come into play as well and then we'll
imagine that we remember a talk a few
years back MSA TL is a really great
clinical conference for mass
spectrometry and I'm giving them a
little bit of recognition because they
in the past years have had an icp-ms
track which i think is fantastic really
highlighting some of the novel
applications of icp-ms at at the same
time dr. julie ray who i did introduce
in my thank you she did present an MS
ACL about using LC tandem mass
spectrometry and some problems that were
encountered a tarry pee when the volumes
increased at this organization so like
many we've developed tests in the past
they're developed with an expectation of
a certain volume when that volume grows
we often times find things that we
didn't anticipate depending upon the
degree of robustness and really just
what you can anticipate when volumes
change so the big catch here is we've
been to a conference we heard a
scientist talk about challenges with LC
triple quad mass spec which is a red
flag right we want to kind of consider
well maybe maybe there's something that
we need to be worried about there and
then the big catch is we only have
enough funds to buy a single instrument
which again is not too big of an unusual
circumstance so we're not going to be
able to bring up backup instruments
right we're not going to be able to do
the very normal laboratory medicine
philosophy of buying two of everything
to make sure we have a backup so we need
to make sure that we get the right
technology turnaround time is important
but what I'm talking about here is not
necessarily turnaround time and
guards to being able to push a result
out quickly but it's really how much
downtime can we actually handle if our
instrument goes down and that goes back
to you know us pretending that we're
remembering this discussion that ms atl
about instrument downtime and so
turnaround time when everything is
operating the way it should be is one
thing turnaround time when instruments
are down obviously very different
situation and then funneling into both
of those is robustness right we really
need to make sure that we pick a
solution that's not going to have an
enormous amounts of downtime not going
to be very finicky and so those are sort
of the three kind of main criteria that
come up in my mind every time I sort of
approach a project amongst other things
as well of course so we're going to go
back and we're going to dig through our
notes we're going to find the
information that we saw presented at
that MS ATL conference by a Julie ray so
the project with art III by LC triple
quad so the basics of this is it was a
96-well plate assay which is good we're
looking at high throughput we don't want
to have individual tubes so that fits
the criteria for what we're looking for
but one thing to kind of keep in mind is
you know that in itself is pretty unique
with different types of mass
spectrometry so really you know volume
is important right we don't want to
develop a method in tubes if we very
well know we're going to have to go to
plates pretty quickly and anybody that
has developed methods in plates or
transition them from tubes to plates can
tell you the manufacturer of plates
there's lots of things that go into the
overall quality and success of the
assays we had a five and a half minute
injection to injection which again you
can very quickly sit down you can figure
out the mass of what your throughput and
what your capacity is going to be with a
five and a half minute injection two
injection will we even be able to
sustain the volume that we actually have
how quickly will we actually overcome
with the capacity that we have you know
all very straightforward things to do
when methods are published in the
literature and presented at conferences
the one issue here that we'll remember
and we'll come back to is that our T 3
and T 3 have to be chromatographic Li
separated and we'll dig into some
superficial details that means between
the different
and you'll kind of see what some of this
terminology means if this is one of the
first times you've come across too but
our T 3 and T 3 have identical mass to
charge ratios so the mass spec really is
not going to be able to tell them apart
very easily if we think about tandem
mass spectrometry well they're going to
have the same fragments so again we're
not going to be able to tell them apart
so chromatographic retention time is the
way that we're going to be able to tell
these compounds separately so I think
that's important to note because we
typically think oftentimes tandem mass
spectrometry has great specificity while
as a single quadrupole doesn't have the
same degree of specificity
it's very contextually dependent and so
important concept to kind of keep in
mind there however the advantage of
course to the LC triple quad mass spec
test is that it's commonly used so it's
great to have users that you can contact
great to have other people who've used
it sometimes it's fun to be the
innovator but probably not if it's your
job every day to run the test and it
doesn't really feel very fun to be an
innovator I'm sure so the bad thing that
we do remember from this is the
instrument fouling so that was one of
the big findings and one of the big
issues that was being presented there
was a constant downtime for cleaning so
that makes us a bit concern because
again we've got to have a robust assay
we don't have a whole lot of we don't
have a whole lot of time for instrument
downtime and we're not going to have
backup instruments so that's something
to be very mindful of and you probably
remember the cost associated with
maintenance right it's not free to take
an instrument down it's not free to
actually clean it so not only do you
actually have lost opportunity cost with
being able to push volume through the
lab but you've got the maintenance costs
on top of that and so some of the data
that was actually presented at that time
that you can see here so Matt Biddy and
Terry veo are both helpful in getting
this is and I was involved in this sort
of initial troubleshooting as we took
some of the washing so the big the big
issue here is they were taking the front
end department having to clean it pretty
far back into the instrument as well and
so what we wanted to do is we wanted to
see what is all over the instrument
right you could kind of see like a white
coating in different places it was
really causing the sensitivity to bottom
out and so fun with
instruments we can actually take that
and I feel like everything eventually
finds its way into an icp-ms to
determine what it might actually be and
so we did this we looked to see what it
was and not surprisingly we found quite
a bit of iodine I have sort of iodine
being called out here with a little box
because typically you don't see big
iodine Peaks like this unless you've
enriched for iodine and so that's
something to kind of keep note here this
is a semi quant
and done in helium mode on an Agilent
7900 and what you're really sort of
appreciating here is there's quite a bit
of iodine that's not that surprising
because we have a method that's
enriching for thyroid hormone which is
iodine containing so we might expect
there to be a lot of iodine but at the
same time there's not much we can do
about that because we have a method
that's enriching for thyroid hormone and
it that's exactly what it needs to do so
this isn't necessarily a problem that we
could address by having pure solvents or
you know switching to a different
extraction method because ultimately
we're going to be pulling potentially
the same things that are causing us
issues so was this the major reason for
downtime we don't know but ultimately
what we know is here's what the
elemental signature was of essentially
in the junk that was on the instrument
we see a lot of iodine so we knew we
needed to do something about this so -
Julie's credit you'll have seen her
present this and regards to what were
the efforts to actually try to address
all of this instrument fouling so we
have new column chemistry that was
looked at to address retention time
shifting so that potentially we could
divert away some of the t42 wastes and
we'll come back to that concept a little
bit regards to what compounds are we
actually looking at when are they coming
off the column and what does that
actually mean for things that can go
into the mass spec versus things that we
could potentially divert to waste looked
at alternative solid phase extraction
stationary phases to try to increase
sample cleanup but again we can increase
sample cleanup certainly but we can't
ever reduce the fact that we are pulling
iodine or iodine containing compounds
out because that's exactly what we're
trying to do so because we had a pretty
good suspicion that it was the iodine
that was causing the problem there's
very little that we felt that ultimately
we deal
to do by trying to change a sample clean
on but we looked at a lot of different
types of and I exchange different types
of solid phase extraction getting ready
getting rid of phospholipids which is
always an interesting experiment to try
and to look at phosphide phospholipid
transitions after with and without
phospholipid removal plates but we tried
a lot of different things and ultimately
what we found out was spent lots of time
put lots of effort into this but we
didn't solve the problem now - Julie's
credit and I think something that's very
interesting for everybody to think about
is you know this was a project that
ended up with no solution for what it
was intended to do but if any of you
actually get got to see this
presentation at MSA TL Julie was able to
combine this with a really interesting
study about traumatic brain injury in
art III at the same time so you know out
of the ashes of a failed project
oftentimes there's still something very
interesting and more importantly what I
think is great a lot about a lot of the
mass spec conferences is you know we're
pretending we are at this conference we
saw this discussion this is helping us
to inform so presenting failures is
often times more interesting I think
than presenting a lot of the successes
that you typically see so we've got sort
of the analytical vignette right we've
got sort of pressure develop an assay
we've got concerns because we've seen
some issues with our go to technology if
you want to call it that and so we're
gonna dive into some of the details here
in regards to you know what are we
actually looking for what technology is
out there in which direction do we
ultimately want to go I said I wasn't
going to spend a lot of time on the
clinical and the research background for
art III because again if you look at
that and a little goals and yet send
outs are climbing you know there's room
to be or there's arguments to be made on
both sides in regards to whether or not
art III should be measured how's it
actually used but ultimately again we're
looking at a financial and a business
decision of you know we need to develop
this test so for that reason we need to
understand just a little bit about these
molecules themselves so t4 largely
considered the inactive or a prohormone
gives rise to t3 there's come there's
enzymes called dia
that will actually as you can see here
take off sort of an outer ring iodine
generating t3 however at the same time
t4 could also go through a different
deionized path to di Odin 8 on an inner
ring generating reverse t3 or RT 3 and
so it's typically thought that you know
T floor has very little activity t3 is
really sort of the main actuator of the
hormone system and then our t3 is
considered to be inactive as well and
that's where I think some of the
contention comes into play in regards to
you know is our t3 does our t3 actually
have function on its own does it not is
it valuable to measure very interesting
research I think in regards to brain
injury with thyroid hormone metabolism
but outside the scope of what we're
talking about today ultimately what you
can take away from this is we've got
three major molecules that we need to
worry about in our assay t3 and our t3
has the exact same mass even though they
have iodine's removed from different
parts of their outer ring structures t4
different mass so when we're looking at
different types of technology you know
having the same mass having different
masses or certainly come into play so
before we actually get to what kind of
detector are we going to use we need to
think a little bit about the front end
speed this is something that I don't
think is oftentimes as well appreciated
in the idea of smaller lower volume
laboratories typically we think of
multiplexing or in this situation where
I'll talk about more is color
regeneration strategies we may think of
those as you know something that large
reference laboratories deal with but in
truth what we're really thinking about
is capacity how do we get more capacity
out of an instrument that we have and
odds are as soon as you buy your first
instrument you're going to very quickly
exceed the capacity either because your
clinical volume grows or possibly
because you now need this instrument for
R&D work that's being consumed by
clinical work so getting samples through
quickly is not necessarily just a large
laboratory problem it's a problem that
everybody needs to think about and
there's some very interesting strategies
out there and so here I'm showing some
of the basic tools that we're going to
be talking about today
so chromatic graphs of columns in the
topper upper-left the key to this is
we're going to have two two columns
identical columns but we're gonna have
two cones we have an isocratic pump in
the mix here we also have a multi
sampler so somewhere where we can sort
of stack samples and kind of leave at
the same time we have the ability to do
overlapped injection and we'll come back
to some of these concepts so you can
appreciate sort of how they fit into
this entire piece binary and quaternary
pumps we have ten port valves so lots of
plumbing involved obviously and what
we're going to be talking about but
extremely important to kind of see what
we can do with a front-end and again
don't think that this is really just a
high volume issue you know what we're
really looking at is throughput in
capacity which is something that
everybody needs to be concerned about
regardless of what your sort of total
volume really kind of is we all want to
get better capacity out of the
instrumentation that we actually
purchase so here you can kind of get an
idea of we have two different pump
systems what can we actually do with
this and so if we look at sort of the
top situation here we have and whenever
the system is in position one we have an
element pump that is going to be driving
through the autosampler and tandem with
the autosampler we're going into
position two which will then come
position three so most of you I'm sure
can appreciate sort of the nuances with
two position valves and so it's either
going to have one in ten connected which
obviously then makes two and three
connected or it's going to have one in
two connected so in this sort of
position one will call this we're going
into two out three we're going to be
going across one of the columns so in
this situation it's called one into six
out seven to the detector so position
one essentially what we have here is a
very normal LC set up we're going to
potentially be running through a
gradient if we have a binary pump set up
very normal sort of situation pump
driving across the column into the
detector however at the same time you
can hopefully also appreciate that we
have a another pump in the mix here as
well we have a regeneration pump now
this regeneration pump is going to be
running independent of the
the eluent pump the regeneration pumps
going to be going into four out five
into ten out one going across the second
column that we have in this system in
eight out nine into waste so essentially
we now have a separate pump system
that's driving through a different sort
of set of positions in the valve into
waste and so hopefully what you can kind
of appreciate now is we have with these
two different pump systems we're able to
actually do very normal typical
chromatography that were kind of used to
but at the same time we have this
separate pump system that's able to be
running on a separate column going into
waste so for any of you who have had a
lot of experience with LC or have done
some LC can probably start to appreciate
where this is going in regards to
efficiencies and where the dead parts
are in a typical sort of LC chromatogram
and how a second pump could actually
come into play but before we move on to
that then we have the idea of course is
now we have a second position so we had
position one now a position to
everything is just reversed right we
have our le one pump going through the
autosampler two to one now going across
column two and then to the detector our
regeneration pump instead is now pushing
mobile phase across column one so it's
just a complete switch right in position
one
we were running across column one in
position two we're running across column
two so we've got sort of that two pump
system running and we're able to
potentially cut down the LC time and
that's what we're going to look at now
in regards to how does this actually
help us to have these two positions so
here's a bit of a description of column
regeneration in action so this isn't
true multiplexing but this is an
interesting strategy in many different
situations especially something like
urine toxicology or even serum
toxicology testing where you have lots
of Peaks you have lots of compounds
you're looking at multiplexing doesn't
always work sometimes there's not a lot
of dead time in the chromatogram but
that's where column regeneration can
still have a huge impact on the total
throughput and we'll kind of take some
look at some of those details as well
but remember one of the big reasons
we're looking at this is not
because we're a massive volume
laboratory it's because we've only got
one potential purchase here for an
instrument so we're gonna have to make
the most out of this instrument and
we're gonna have to be mindful of the
fact that once we put our clinical
volume on there we're gonna have to have
some bandwidth for maintenance we're
gonna have to have some potential
bandwidth for R&D work if we want to do
more work on it
so worrying about capacity is always
something that we should think about
sooner rather than later so in this
column regeneration strategy then we
have two different column systems we're
going to imagine that our starting
conditions are going to be 70% a and 30%
B so column one we're gonna be at
starting condition 70/30 with the what
we'll call analytical pumps column two
however is going to be at the same
starting condition but it's going to be
run off of the separate separate set of
pumps or the so called regeneration
pumps so we've got same mobile phase
composition running across two pumps
running from two pumps across two
independent columns right now so that's
what you can sort of imagine as a
starting point so the analytical pump
system is going to run through the
gradient so in this case it'll start
from 70% a and we'll go all the way down
to 5% a so 95% B is what we're going to
end up with so the analytical pump will
run the LC gradient like you would
expect start to final and then I put a
little plus there because we'll take a
look and see when we do this column
regeneration strategy we have to have a
short little wash step at the end to
make sure that the mobile phase lines
are actually at the right composition
and then separately of that we have a
regeneration pump that's set to final
conditions which will then flip to
starting conditions so now you're
starting to hopefully appreciate this
idea behind the analytical pump running
from starting conditions through the end
of the gradient and then we have a
separate regeneration pump that's going
to be able to run from ending conditions
and get us back to start so a typical
idea is we're going to inject on to
column 1 we're going to run through that
gradient column 1 is going to reach its
final condition like normal we're gonna
shortly or we're going to do a really
quick switch to starting conditions to
essentially flush out all of the mobile
phase lines and then we're going to have
our valve that's going to switch to the
next position and now in that situation
column 1 is going to now be in line with
the regeneration pump which is that
final condition so we're going to start
meaning off column one column two is now
going to be driven by the analytical
pump which is going to run again through
the next gradient so we'll take a little
bit of a closer look at this in regards
to what type of what type of gradient
positions that we're actually going to
have and again this entire sort of
everything I'll show here a lot of stuff
was done initially in pure solvents at
this point it's mostly been serum one of
the questions was what type of materials
have we actually used and so serum was
what this test was really designed for
but in truth that's one of the
advantages I think of the icp-ms that
we'll take a look at is we need to be
worried about the LC system the
cleanliness of the LC system but we
don't have to worry as much about the
robustness of the mass spec system and
we'll hopefully kind of cover that when
we look at some of the different
technologies so here's a cartoon to kind
of give you an idea of well how does
this alternating a column regeneration
strategy really help to increase
throughput increase capacity so if you
look at the very top line here so this
is very normal sort of effort right
sequential runs so we're all familiar
with the idea here I'm trying to get my
pointer to come up here we go so
sequential runs we have our drawn inject
cycle which can sometimes be anywhere
from 30 seconds to a minute depending
upon what we're doing we have our
gradient we have our column wash
equilibration and then we're ready to go
again right so this would be five and a
half minutes injection two injection
where we're ready to do another
injection cycle so now if we compare
this to using an isocratic regeneration
pump we can't run a gradient on that
isocratic system but we can run sort of
one composition of mobile phase and so
now what we can do is we can take this
call on the collaboration step then we
can run it in parallel when it makes
sense to do this so now we have our draw
and inject cycle our gradient run our
column wash we have this little rinse
step that's now involved so that way we
can clean out the mobile phase lines but
then rather than having to wait for the
equilibrate to occur we can go straight
back to direct injection
are drawn inject into the gradient
because we're going to switch the valve
and we're going to use that second pump
system to do the equilibria so here's
where you can see a little bit of time
savings already is we can have one
column in line with the analytical pump
running the gradient as soon as it's
done we can switch over let a separate
pump system run the equilibration and we
can get right back to doing analytical
gradient on the freshly equilibrate at
home so that's great that's a time
savings for sure and some of the figures
here you know they may or may not apply
depending upon what your gradient
actually is the speed but it's a good
example overall so now if we were to
take that isocratic regeneration pump
and turn it into a gradient pump okay
now what else could we do we can take
this wash step and we can actually move
this wash step to the separate pump
system and we no longer have to have
that wash system part of that linear
process that we have for the analytical
pump so now we have our draw inject
gradient run we have that small rinse
cycle that we had to impose and then
we're right back to going to draw and
inject because now we can switch the
valve and we can have the regeneration
pump run both the wash and equilibration
step so now you're starting to see a
little bit of how these pumps are going
to be running parallel to one another to
ultimately save time and then lastly
sort of a newer feature right continuing
to increase our throughput we can now
look at what if we could do so-called
overlapped injection where rather than
the auto sampler sitting there and
waiting for the gradient to finish what
if we could tell the auto sampler to go
ahead and get started and that way we
don't have to wait for that 30 seconds
to a minute for the inject cycle to
occur so now as you can kind of see not
only over using two separate pumps but
now we're also using a higher end auto
sampler to be able to do overlapped
injection we can really start increasing
our capacity what's interesting is we
haven't had to make any compromises to
the gradient we didn't have to make any
compromises to the equilibration to the
washing so we can take care of our LC
system and our columns the same that we
would want to but we're able to run
these processes in parallel so that we
can actually just reduce the time that
we're spending and waiting for one step
to finish to move on to another
so here's where you can hopefully kind
of appreciate that you know this is not
really true multiplexing what this
really does have considerable throughput
in regards to the time that we can save
you know with this giving an indication
of about sixty percent of the total time
with this alternate strategy you're
getting very very close to being able to
actually double your capacity on a
single instrument that's a very
attractive proposition even in a
laboratory that's not super high-volume
right again we want to try to be as
efficient as possible in a different
testing that we actually do so hopefully
that was a decent overview of the LC
system it's a huge component to this
because we have to remember that initial
constraint which is we're not really
going to be able to you know we're not
going to be able to worry about having a
secondary system you know we're not
going to be able to worry about having a
lot of downtime right we want to have a
robust method gives us good turnaround
time but capacity and throughput is
something we really can spend some time
on the LC system and now whether we
picked a triple quad whether we pick an
icp-ms whether we actually pick Q toss
whatever you want to potentially use now
we've got as efficient as possible as a
front-end so we can really make sure
that we're as efficient as possible on
the back end well we're still not out of
the water right because that initial
analytical problem told us that we need
to be very careful about the different
technology that we think so now to be
able to kind of give you a little bit of
an understanding very quick background
they don't want to belabor how each one
of these technologies works because I
doubt anybody signed up for this webinar
to understand the details of mass
spectrometry but I imagine there are
some of you that maybe have not had as
much experience and I want to be able to
show off my amazing drawing talent and
so for that reason we'll kind of
systematically go through here and look
at the different technologies and we'll
think of this in terms of we're trying
to decide what technology do we want to
use and so we're going to start with
tandem mass spectrometry and take a look
at you know what makes tandem mass
spectrometry unique and what really
makes it sort of a powerful technology
the first requirement was any type of
spectrometry is getting ions in the gas
phase and most often we see electrospray
ionisation being used this complex
process can be understood for small
molecules by imagining small droplets
forming from the liquid flow off the
Kamata graphic column it is through a
combination of heat and high voltage
that highly charged droplets are
generated if you look closer at the
droplets we can see the process of
Coulomb fission generating successively
smaller droplets until I evaporation
occurs and we are left with ions in the
gas phase and our mass spectrometer can
finally get to work it is important to
note that the mass spectrometer will see
ions as mass divided by the charge for
most small molecules a single charge is
present so the mass overcharge ratio is
equal to the mass but this isn't always
a case where multiple charges are
present after being guided into the high
vacuum of the mass spectrometer the ions
will encounter the first quadrupole and
undergo a mass filtering event based on
flight stabilization a combination of
voltages produces oscillating electric
fields that will select for a narrow
window of masses although a single
quadrupole provides specificity the use
of tandem mass spectrometry further
enhances the specificity the process of
collision induced dissociation occurs
after the first mass filtering event has
completed and inert gas fills the
collision cell and the filtered ions
collide and reproducible fragments are
generated based on the energy supplied
to the collision cell we can change the
ratio of fragments that are generated
giving us an important characteristic
and molecule identification after
dissociation the 2nd mass filtering
event occurs through a similar flight
stabilization process noted earlier
combinations of voltages produces an
oscillating electric field and we are
able to select fragments to eventually
be registered at the detector this
combination of mass filtering
fragmentation and secondary mass
filtering provides the overall
specificity of tandem mass spectrometry
not only does a molecule need the right
mass it also needs to generate the right
fragments in the right ratios for a
positive identification
okay so hopefully that gives you a
little bit of an overview in regards to
tandem mass spectrometry hopefully you
didn't learn anything too deep there but
just kind of a nice sort of cartoon
illustration of what make tandem mass
spectrometry really that unique but the
odds are if we're in this laboratory
that we're pretending we're doing this
sort of art III thought experiment we
probably have some expertise with tandem
aspect we appreciate the idea of
transitions but as I kind of mentioned
earlier we're still gonna have to worry
about chromatographic separation so if
we're going to be trying to push through
put and get a lot of capacity out of our
instrument we're not going to be able to
have a whole lot of play with that with
a chromatic chromatography time because
we're going to have to make sure that
the compound stays separated so a
technology that a lot of people I'm sure
have heard about there's already CPT
codes associated with time of flight
mass spect and it's certainly growing in
popularity although I think it's
probably still not quite ready to find a
home in the majority of laboratories but
a very interesting technology for lots
of different reasons so we'll take a
look now about time-of-flight mass spec
technology that most likely many of you
don't have as much expertise with but at
the same time something that's out there
we do want to take a look at this
because again the whole point of really
kind of having a discussion like this is
you know did we do our due diligence to
understand what might we actually get
using one type of technology versus
another type of technology we won't go
over iron formation again but is
important to note that the gas phase
ions are key to being able to separate
molecules using any type of mass
spectrometry for time-of-flight mass
spec instead of filtering ions with a
combination of voltages we instead line
up a discreet packet of ions give them
all an equal push into the flight tube
with a pulsar by giving all the ions a
saint's push lighter ions will go faster
in comparison to larger ions we push
them on the same direction towards the
high vacuum flight tube where they will
start their journey towards the detector
to enhance the ability the time of
flight instrument to tell the difference
between molecules with a similar mass we
can use a reflect
this serves to reduce the spread of
energies that similar ions might have so
that ions are the same mass at the
detector at the same time without a
reflector on the mass spectrometer could
miss identify the same compounds as
having different masses based on
different arrival times at the detector
at this point we wait for ions of
different masses to arrive at the
detector with light ions arriving first
followed by successively heavier ions
time-of-flight has a major advantage
over tandem mass spectrometry and that
ions of an entire mass range of interest
are allowed to eventually reach the
detector this gives us high ion
transmission that can be helpful when we
are measuring lots of ions and short
periods of time
okay so that's time-of-flight mass
spectrometry so hopefully we're gaining
a little bit of an appreciation for ion
transmission that's really I think one
of the major differences between triple
quad and common flight for a triple quad
at any given time we're going to have to
be looking at a specific mass and with
tandem mass spectrometry we're going to
be looking at a specific mass to charge
transition to another mass to charge or
a fragment so the overall throughput of
the different ions we're looking at
we're going to be a bit limited to be
fair modern mass spectrometers
quadrupole mass spectrometers they cycle
very fast but there is going to be a
limitation depending upon how complex
the analysis is that we're doing
time-of-flight has some huge advantages
in that aspect and in regards to very
fast chromatography or lots of different
compounds wanting to be looked at at any
given time but certainly single stage
time of flight mass spectrometry has its
limitations even though you might hear
it called high resolution mass spec
you'd be surprised if you haven't used
it before
how many compounds have the exact same
accurate mass so it's definitely
something where you need to be worried
about specificity if it's being used in
a definitive way you need to make sure
certainly that you understand all the
limitations there so we've got the idea
of triple quadrupole mass spec which I'm
guessing most people are pretty
comfortable with we move on to
time-of-flight mass spec which I would
say at this point if I was in the
position of this individual trying to
decide doesn't seem like it quite fits
we're not really doing huge numbers of
compounds we're not really doing
presumptive testing or any kind of
screening so triple quadrupole still
seems to be sort of the front-runner of
course the problem is the reason that
we're thinking about different
technology is because of what we've
heard sort of through the grapevine and
presented at conferences in regards to
what's actually kind of potentially
going to be a problem for us using a
triple quadrupole technology so I could
be a mess it may be something a lot of
you have expertise with it may be some
something that some of you do not have
expertise with we're going to take a
look a look at icp-ms now before we
finish up and take a look at how the RT
3 by LC ICP
method actually worked
and that gives a couple
plasma mass spectrometry is the same as
what we discussed with tandem mass
spectrometry except with a different ion
source and most often with only a single
quadrupole used gas phase ions are still
needed and the first step for icp-ms to
separate small droplets from large by
using a spray chamber this ensures only
the smallest droplets move on in the
process the small droplets are vaporized
atomized and then ionized in the
inductively coupled plasma ion source
the torch has a gas supplied such as
argon an initial spark of energy causes
electrons to be liberated magnetic field
that results from the oscillating
voltages and the torch coils accelerates
electrons and sustains a plasma at an
energy capable of ionizing most atoms at
Hunter it is important to note that an
icp-ms the ion source is very harsh so
even though whole molecules go in one
side only ionized elements come out the
other structure of compounds is lost
which is an important concept to
remember for later once we have gas
phase ions we eventually encounter the
mass filtering quadrupole as before
where we select specific ions to reach
the detector and using combinations of
voltages and flight stabilization and
the oscillating electric fields the
single quadruples are most common tandem
mass spectrometers are available with
inductively coupled plasma zazz the ion
source
okay so we've had our kind of quick view
of the different technologies what they
have to offer some of the strengths
maybe some of the weaknesses kind of
jumped out to some of you who either
used one or maybe used all of them I
think the important thing to think about
here is an icp-ms it's just a different
ion source but it's a quadrupole it's
unique in the sense that it typically
only does positive mode so we don't do
negative mode analyses with it which can
actually reduce the cost which is a bit
of an attractive component to it
slightly different plumbing slightly
different gases that you actually have
to have but in this scenario where for
thinking about fibroid hormone analysis
we don't necessarily need to worry about
being inside of a cleanroom worrying
about any of those kinds of aspects that
we might think about if we're using an
IT PMS for trace element analysis when
those regulations type of a kind of
apply so for that reason it's a very
interesting of very interesting
technology because of the robustness if
you think back to the beginning of that
clinical vignette we talked about
needing robustness right that was sort
of the important point we're only going
to have one instrument we're gonna have
to have high throughput if we want to be
able to utilize the instrument fully but
we need something that's going to be
able to handle everything that we can
essentially throw at it
you can probably appreciate that the ion
source doesn't get much harsher than a
plasma which is obviously close to
surface of the Sun kind of temperature
but now there's a limitation that we
talked about there and hopefully you
could appreciate is that when we look at
what we're measuring we're measuring
independent elements we're not measuring
structures so we don't have transitions
like we do in triple quadrupole mass
spec and so initially you may think well
that's a limitation we need to be able
to look at structures in order to use
mass spectrometer to be able to measure
thyroid hormones specifically but again
if you think back to a triple quadrupole
mass spec it can't tell the difference
between t3 and r83 either they have to
meet chromatographic ly separated so
it's the same situation where we have
with an LC icp-ms we're going to be
looking at iodine and we're going to
need to know which species it comes from
so it's going to be
to the LC method that we're actually
looking at so putting all these pieces
together then we've got the LC system
that we can configure for higher
throughput independent of what type of
detector or mass spectrometer we're
actually going to be using but in this
case we're going to be looking at using
an icp-ms and I want to highlight the
fact that this is not a new concept to
measure tyroid hormones by icp-ms but
it's certainly not something that has
found its way into sort of routine
clinical use and I think primarily just
because of the comfort level that a lot
of people have with LC triple quadrupole
mass spectrometry and sometimes often
some of the published literature has
been done in urine here we're obviously
primarily worried about serum and the
sensitivities in the past have not
always been where they needed to be so
there are some limitations this is not
going to be a perfect out-of-the-box
solution but it's certainly something
that is of interest and now one of the
reasons why at at the time at ATP we
were the most interested in exploring
icp-ms as a potential possibility is we
had icp-ms in-house so that's a huge
reduction in risk we don't have to make
an investment in the technology that
were not already comfortable with and
don't already understand sort of the
strengths and weaknesses that it
actually has the other aspect I
mentioned earlier that's also very
important is we did have we had already
converted a lot of our technology over
to 96-well based testing that's a pretty
unique concept for anybody who spent
time in a clinical icp-ms sort of
laboratory 96-well plates are not
typically what you would normally see so
for that reason for a laboratory to go
from you know potentially you know 15 ml
tubes to a 96-well plate that itself can
be a bit of a dramatic shift but as I
mentioned we had already kind of made
this shift we've been using the C TAC in
the x70 100's a low volume auto sampler
integrated nicely with the Agilent
technology that we actually had and we
already had iodine serum and urine
assays running and if you think about it
the typical prep for icp-ms testing is a
dilute and shoot method and we never had
any problems with the icp-ms running
iodine and so for that reason we thought
well this is a very robust technology
it's already running the matrix that
we're looking at so maybe this is
something that we could actually explore
knowing that we could actually resolve
the compound
pramatta graphically prior to putting
them into the I CTMS so one of the major
advantages and one of the applications
that's out there that I think has really
kind of made this a reality to look into
is the use of an organic Storch and I'm
not going to go into too many of the
details with that but it's essentially a
bit of a smaller overall orifice on the
sample injector so it reduces the amount
of solvent going into the plasma and at
the same time we're able to tee in an
oxygen gas to be able to help the
combustion of the solvents that we're
putting in
typically for icp-ms you know high
stalls and high organic solvents are not
what you would expect could be easily
tolerated for icp-ms but with some
advances in the last few years or so
that's definitely not the case anymore
so the interesting thing here is we
already had a method running you could
consider this a method that you found in
the literature we actually had a method
at area P that we are already running
and so the idea about being able to sort
of just cut and paste a method from a
triple quadrupole detector system over
to an icp-ms system was readily
available and so that's exactly what we
did and that's what that top graphic is
actually showing you this is a gradient
that we took straight off of the LC
triple quad system that we had so
science
5500 system and we moved it directly
over to the LC icp-ms system now the
flow rates were a little bit different
because we could actually handle a
higher flow rate on the icp-ms system
but overall we were able to go straight
out of the box no configuration to the
chromatography exact same mobile phases
and compositions so we had a method up
and running very quickly we didn't have
to do anything specific just because we
were using an icp-ms however if you look
at this chromatogram what you can
hopefully appreciate as we've got a peak
there being identified as RT 3 that's
actually T 3 and the our T 3 and T 4
peak are actually kind of smushed
together and now on a triple quadrupole
not a big deal T 3 and T 4 have or our T
3 and T 4 for that matter have different
masses so we don't have to worry about
the fact that the T 4 peak is kind of
swallowing up the RT 3 peak in our
chromatogram however on an icp-ms this
is a huge issue because again every
that goes into the mass spect is going
to be vaporized atomized and ionized so
it's only going to be a Adan coming out
the other side not p4 or t3 so even
though we could potentially cut and
paste a method that we had seen we were
going to have to do a little bit of LC
configuration because we do need to get
rid of this t4 interference from our t3
but that's kind of highlights I think
one of the most important aspects of
this that we really have to be careful
about is looking into the specificity
right anytime you use a new technology
the specificity can always kind of bite
you if you haven't come across those
issues before so fun with gradients I'm
going to pretend like it only took me
three iterations to actually get this
done but obviously that's not how LC
works at least that's not how I work for
LC but we did some scouting and we were
able to actually fairly quickly be able
to get baseline resolution of t3 our t3
and t4 so that's the out of the aleutian
sort of order in which they come off so
t4 is the first peak that you see coming
off followed by I'm sorry t3 is the
first peak our t3 is in the middle and
then t4 is the last paint to come off so
baseline resolution great specificity
but again even though we know that this
is t3 our t3 and t4 the icp-ms is purely
just looking at iodine so again iodine
is really sort of the metal or the
element that we're actually measuring in
this situation to give us the
specificity for iodine so that's a
performance objective so I'll spend it's
just a couple of slides here at the end
kind of showing you where this method is
this isn't a method validation
presentation so I'm not going to show
all the details there but I will kind of
give you the idea that overall the
sensitivity is what sort of sidelined
this a little bit not to mention my time
winding down at ATP and not and no
longer having the ability to kind of
continue to work on the project but we
were about three-fold less sensitive
than what we really wanted to be even
using sort of a dilute and shoot as well
as a concentration step and I think a
lot of that had to do with the order ICP
that we were using and we had some ideas
as to
we might be able to boost that
sensitivity one of the really important
experiments I think we needed to do and
I was very happy with the outcome is we
were able to put a very high
concentration of t3 and we were able to
put a very high concentration of t4 so
this is about a hundred times higher
than what the AMR the upper end of the
AMR was and then we were able to put in
a normal amount of our t3 so about in
the middle of the AMR for our t3 and
this experiment is important because as
everybody knows when you get very high
concentrations of compounds you can
start having tailing with a tandem mass
spectrometer if we have our samples well
resolved by mass we might not have to
worry about that but this could be a
major issue for an icp-ms where again
we're only looking at iodine and so this
gives us a lot of confidence that with
the chromatography that we developed we
would easily be able to resolve these
compounds even if we had super
physiological amounts of t3 and t4 we'd
still get a good measure of our t3 you
can kind of see on the right what the
chromatograms looked like as we went
from standard one that was about 12.5
pica grams per mil to tender and four
which was 250 pica grams per mil you can
see obviously some performance of QC 1
QC 2 overall we had a bit of an accuracy
issue at the low end and a lot of that
had to do with sensitivity and some of
that had to do more specifically with
some carryover that we actually hadn't
identified and this becomes kind of
interesting I put column carry over here
with a question mark one of the really
interesting things about icp-ms that we
have to worry about is called memory
effects in the spray chamber iodine is
notorious for sticking in the spray
chamber and being able to sort of bleed
into that next sample and so for that
reason we had a bit of a higher
background which was inhibiting our
sensitivity but it did look like we had
probably a little bit of column
carryover and so we would need to do a
little bit of adjustments to make sure
that we can actually reduce this now one
of the really interesting things about
icp-ms that you can also do is you can
do an infusion into that spray chamber
and so one of the questions that you
might actually kind of have is well how
are we going to do internal standard
compensation when we're not getting any
kind of structures you know typically we
might have like a
teensy analog that we'd be looking at
and in this chromatogram what I'm kind
of showing you here is some robustness
with patients that also has an internal
standard in it so not necessarily
looking at the area counts here but
again just looking at from sample one to
sample last getting very good
chromatography a very good overall
sensitivity and not seeing a lot of
drop-off and so this gets to that idea
of robustness you know would we be able
to push samples in over and over and
over again and not have to worry about
the background or not have to worry
about sort of the sensitivity dropping
and then in the top right I kind of just
show this idea of an internal standard
infusion where you can kind of do a
point-to-point correction and this is a
way to be able to do normalization with
an icp-ms using a different element a
different mass that we'd be measuring so
slightly different concept and so
putting in then in there just to really
say that you know this is not just a
simple cut and paste to a different
technology you know there are different
challenges like there are with any
technology but all of them are solvable
and addressable for sure so in summary
have a couple minutes left I just wanted
to leave you with a couple of thoughts
so the first is that LC icp-ms is a
viable option for metal containing
compounds I think I was pretty well
known for searching through everybody's
test catalog to see if there was
anything we could do by icp-ms instead
of by another type of mass spectrometry
the elliptical sensitivity for me was
not as good and again I was on an
Agilent 7700 and so we had proposed that
maybe on 7900 or even moving to some of
the triple quad icp-ms is that we might
be able to reduce the background and
overall get our sensitivity to be better
at the low end where we were looking for
the lower cost of icp-ms is attractive
again it's only running in positive mode
and so some of the electronics and sort
of the internal components are a little
bit less and so for that reason a very
interesting sort of cost lowered
solution the other thing to think about
in regards to robustness as you
oftentimes when you talk to people who
use IT pms you'll talk about icp-ms
instruments sort of in the back of
trucks driving around the desert looking
for water to test very robust
instruments so for that reason very
interesting applications that can be
done
we also looked at high throughput
capacity in the autosampler hopefully I
was able to kind of make the point that
we can worry about capacity no matter
where we're at right it's not just a
high-volume laboratory problem but we
all need to be thinking about capacity
not only for planning for the future but
also just to make sure that we can make
the most out of the instruments that we
have touch briefly on the organics torch
for any of those for any of you who are
icp-ms individuals you know ninety-five
percent to see tonight trowel is not
something you can typically use but
using that organics torch with an oxygen
flow is something that allows you to go
up to 95 percent to see the Nitro
extremely helpful to be able to have
conventional chromatography to not have
to go down the route of any kind of ion
exchange chromatography and then the
idea to with icp-ms is dilute and shoot
we're not worried about dirtiness of the
instrument at this point we're really
just worried about the LC system and
what can the LC system handle we know
that the icp-ms system can actually
handle diluted serum straight into the
system so with that I wanted to thank
you again for your attention
contact information in case for some
reason I didn't get a chance to answer
anything if I didn't cover something in
more detail that you would like to have
covered happy to answer any questions
now or in the future thanks again for
your attention and to everybody for
helping with this webinar thank you dr.
Stratman for your presentation a quick
reminder for our audience on how to
submit questions simply type them in the
Q&A box found like clicking on the green
Q&A button at the lower left of the
presentation window dr. Stratman will
answer as many questions as time permits
so the first question is if a lab has
experience with icp-ms but not LC how
difficult is it to develop an LC icp-ms
method so I think if you don't have
experience with LC I think LC is is
underappreciated and how complex it
really can be so I think the laboratory
has icp-ms experiment experience you've
got a huge component to being able to
essentially make sure that you're going
to be used
method correctly I had talked about you
know iodine and having memory effects
there are things called polyatomics that
we don't typically deal with in triple
quadrupole and other types of technology
that we do in icp-ms so it can't be
overlooked that that's a huge amount of
information that's extremely valuable
but at the same time you know LC really
can throw people for a loop when they've
never done anything except direct
injection which is really what the
majority of icp-ms methods are and so i
would say that a laboratory that has
strong LC experience would most likely
have an easier time transitioning to an
LC icp-ms method than a laboratory that
has icp-ms and transitioning to an LC
icp-ms that's sort of my own opinion I'm
sure there's a lot of people that might
actually argue against that but I think
that's sort of really just appreciating
the complexity in the LC sort of method
development as well as sort of the
ongoing maintenance and addressing of
any kind of issues in the future looks
like we have time for one more question
if the lab has experience with LC ms/ms
but not icp-ms how difficult is it to
translate methods to LC icp-ms yes I
think that's kind of the the kind of the
opposite side of that sort of situation
so I think I probably have overall
addressed out pretty well I really think
that the the LC portion can be
complicated everybody knows I'm sure
that if you pick a method from the you
pick a method from the literature the LC
is most likely not going to go exactly
as you had expected and you know there's
nuances to every type of technology but
I think really having the background in
LC is extremely valuable specifically
because of what we're going to need to
do to ensure specificity as we go into
an icp-ms system so I see a couple other
questions I don't know is that okay if I
go ahead and sort of answer some of
those questions as well or would you
like them or do you want to adjust
something yourself just let me know yeah
I'll go ahead and I'll go ahead and try
to run through a couple of questions as
I kind of noticed everybody kind of
heading out I know we're at the end of
the hour it looks like they have a
question about are you doing the free
hormones and are the ratios of the
analytes of added
take value so this was not looking at
free hormones and I would largely agree
that I don't think the sensitivity that
we have would have anywhere near enough
to be able to do the free hormones by
l-c icp-ms at this point however I do
think as we had talked about being able
to kind of boost some of the sensitivity
you know icp-ms is interesting because
you know only about 2 to 3% of the
sample actually makes it into the mass
spectrometer so there are a ways to
boost the overall sensitivity outside of
just using a different technology but at
the same time being able to actually
look at whether or not they're much
lower sensitivity in regards to sort of
diagnostic value you know I definitely
think sort of free hormones are of
interest I talked about a scientist
early Julie Ray she had a recent
publication looking at chronic opioid
and unconventional sort of pain
medication such as gabapentin pregabalin
looking at free hormone changes and so I
definitely think that the idea between
free and total hormones is something
that has gotten a lot of attention a lot
of people are interested in and there's
definitely a lot of value in looking at
free hormones whether or not there's
value in free rt3 I won't wander into
that that's where an endocrinologist to
discuss not my area of expertise
cost per run to get the three analytical
values so pretty much it's in line with
what you would expect from an icp-ms at
assay that uses LC so analogous to maybe
a LC icp-ms method for arsenic
fractionation
you know we hadn't completely worked out
the idea of would we be doing a diluting
shoot I have seen some dilute and shoot
serum methods that use LC certainly
there's always a concern about
robustness and clogging of columns but
using a guard column you might be able
to get away with that and reduce the
cost so certainly not having to do any
kind of extractions or anything like
that would dramatically reduce the cost
you know the running of the icp-ms I
think is probably cheaper than a triple
quad the maintenance is a bit cheaper
but some of that sort of works its way
out in the wash as well so overall I
would say I don't have any perfect sort
of finalized sort of cost numbers but we
definitely were predicting that it was
going to be cheaper for the laboratory
to run by elf
the icp-ms as compared to LC triple quad
certainly if we could get rid of those
maintenance bills that was another kind
of component as well and turnaround time
comparison between triple quad and ICP
so again
turnaround time very subjective you know
the analysis time on the icp-ms versus
the triple quad is nearly identical the
chromatography you could see we had
actually sped the chromatography up
quite a bit going from a 5.5 injection
to injection to about less than one
point five minutes injection two
injection and that was really before we
had kind of dialed in the overlapped
injection and really got in the column
regeneration strategy finished so
overall much faster so for that reason I
do think the turnaround time would be
much better capacity overall would be
good on the icp-ms compared to the
triple quad I think that's all the
question so thanks to everybody who
submitted questions and again thanks to
Sonia for moderating and for Agilent
sponsoring and laberd's for putting on
this webinar thank you so much thank you
and I would like to once again thank dr.
Stratman for his presentation do you
have any final comment no not at all I
hopefully everybody found this
educational if you're using icp-ms
hopefully you can appreciate there's a
lot more you can do with it and maybe
what you've done thank you to a couple
of the different conferences I had
mentioned MS ACL they have an icp-ms
track which is fantastic the winter
conference on plasma spectra chemistry
is another really great icp-ms
conference a lot of very cool research
and also clinical applications in this
area so hopefully this has gotten
everybody thinking a little bit about
what type of technologies are out there
and how we might be able to apply them
differently than what we had typically
thought
well thank you again and I'd like to
thank the audience for joining us today
and for their interesting questions
those who have additional questions can
send them to dr. Stratman directly we
would also like to thank our sponsor
agilent technologies for underwriting
today's educational webcast this webinar
has been approved for continuing
educational credits please click on the
CD button at the bottom left corner and
follow the process to receive your
credits this webcast can be viewed
on-demand through october 5th 2017 lab
routes will alert you via email when
it's available for replay and we
encourage you to share that an email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event until next time
goodbye